[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a date is set for a new penalty phase in
the trial of scott peterson
convicted in 2004 of killing his wife
lacey
plus legal troubles surrounding three
rap artists
and actor johnny depp suddenly gives up
a movie role
because of his own court matters also a
verdict in the trial of an iowa mother
accused of murdering her child
and then he was hamilton county
prosecutor
he's got his own law firm and everything
he's only 65 years old
a touching interview with a woman who
comforted a dying attorney
police are still looking for the person
who took his life
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome to law and crime daily
everybody i'm erin keller along with
brian buckmeyer and terry austin let's
all begin in california where convicted
wife killer scott peterson is fighting
to get a new trial
peterson was found guilty and sentenced
to death for murdering his wife lacey
and their unborn child on christmas eve
in 2002.
the state supreme court ordered
peterson's death penalty overturned and
his conviction re-examined
all because of possible misconduct by a
juror
peterson appeared virtually in court and
waived his right to a speedy retrial
the judge indicated peterson's penalty
face could be retried
in january twenty one mark garagos
represented peterson at his first trial
and believes that people lied during the
jury selection process
in order to get picked i
called at the time stealth jurors
meaning jurors who were lying
and had an agenda to get on here and
frankly every single one that we
identified
was lying to get on here to convict him
we caught
a couple of them in real time this juror
we did not
and she is obviously a troubled young
woman
and and the subsequent investigation
showed that when she filled out the
forms she had absolutely lied about the
uh fact that she had had a restraining
order and that she had had an
encounter with another woman and that
was exactly what another juror who we
had found and exposed during vaudier
had done and then later that that other
juror had admitted that she was lying
to get on there to fry scott her words
fry scott
so this is a significant issue obviously
i've maintained
for close to 17 years that scott is
innocent and that this was a
this was a mob verdict and hopefully now
he'll get the justice he deserves
okay this is a big case everybody has an
opinion terry let's start with yours the
issue of venue appears to remain on hold
for now because this case is
bouncing back and forth between a couple
of counties wouldn't they want to
straighten out the venue
issue before picking a date for the
penalty phase of the case
you know that would be the logical order
of issues aaron but i think whether the
case is in san mateo like peterson wants
or whether it's in stanislaus county as
the prosecution is saying they want
peterson really has the right to assert
his you know
speedy trial and regardless of what the
venue is so
under the sixth amendment of the u.s
constitution we know he has every right
to do so so
they can sort of skip the order here and
determine one issue
before they actually determine the venue
issue
so brian january 2021 seems like an
awfully
fast date for the penalty phase of a
case after a defendant
waves his right to a speedy trial
january is pretty speedy
yeah it seems like it's right around the
corner of course everyone has a right to
speedy trial and only the defendant has
that ability to wave it
and so what i think the judge is trying
to do here is say you'll wave it but
not too long we don't want that right to
extend past a breaking point
so terry how serious are the juror
issues in your opinion here should a
judge
order an entirely new trial because of
these issues
that mark garrick has talked about new
trial start to finish and not just a new
penalty phase
you know aaron that's also a very
difficult question because i do think
he's guilty but it
is a serious issue if in fact that juror
lied about
the fact that she had a legal proceeding
this was juror number seven
and she lied because she wanted to get
on the jury and she wanted to quote
unquote
fry peterson that would be enough
frankly to
send it back for an entirely new trial
so while people think that peterson is
guilty
he did not get a fair shake there and i
think it might be
right to get a whole new trial as much
as i don't want to say that
okay so brian take off the public
defender hat put on the judicial robe
here just for purposes of this show
should there be a new trial there should
be a new trial and the reason for it is
not because of the defendant but because
of the system
if we are going to uphold this system of
being
tried by a jury of your peers that are
fair and impartial that has to apply to
the guilty
as well as the innocent and to ensure
that the system works the way it's
supposed to
due process is very important i agree
with you there
rest of the opinions we may differ on
but i agree on that
actor johnny depp announcing a
resignation from his warner brothers
role on the fantastic
beasts while promising a legal appeal
depp posted this letter to instagram
saying
allegations raised against him were in
his words false
depp sued a british newspaper for
calling him a wife beater
but the newspaper recently won he called
that legal judgment
surreal depp and his ex-wife amber heard
have been locked in legal battles of
their own leading up to
and surrounding their divorce heard says
depp abused her
depp says heard abused him and let's
turn now to brian buckmeyer with several
legal issues surrounding rap artists or
in the case of takashi 69
they're kidnappers brian erin so a man
with gang ties has been sentenced for
kidnapping rapper takashi 6-9
anthony harv ellison will spend 24 years
in prison
after he was convicted of kidnapping
racketeering and violent assault
ellison is said to be a member of the
nine trade gangsta bloods
rapper takashi 6 9 testified that
ellison and another man kidnapped him at
gunpoint back in 2018.
the rapper whose real name is daniel
hernandez said he joined the bloods but
was never initiated
he testified that as a part of a plea
deal
to allow him to have a lesser sentence
in his own case
lawyers for one of the men charged with
xxx tentacion's shooting death
are trying to get evidence thrown out of
the case michael
lil boltright is accused of shooting the
rapper
trying to steal his louis vuitton bag
that had fifty thousand dollars of cash
inside
boats right attorneys say that he was
not mentally competent and he was under
the influence of marijuana when he spoke
to the detectives xxx tente sione's
whose birth name was jashish offroy was
killed in his bmw after he withdrew cash
from a bank
boatwright and three other men are
charged with first-degree murder
a trial date has yet to be set a rapper
charge in the double murder of his own
friends is now being sued for millions
by the families of the alleged victims
ynw
melli whose birth name is jamella demons
is accused of shooting two men in his
car
staging the shooting to look like a
drive-by and then dropping the bodies
off at the hospital
mellie was known for working with kanye
west and had released a music video
called murder on my mind the lawsuit
claims a rapper killed his two crew
members
after dispute about money the families
are asking for a jury trial
and damages in the millions brian thanks
a lot for the updates and still ahead on
law and crime daily a judge admits a
mistake in the case
involving one of the four police
officers accused of murdering george
floyd
but first a verdict from a judge in the
case of an iowa mother accused of
murdering her five-year-old daughter
that's next on lawn crime daily
[Music]
there is a verdict to report in the case
of an iowa mother accused of murdering
her five-year-old daughter
this one's a little bit tricky though
prosecutors claimed kelsey thomas
strangled chloe thomas with her own
pajama pants
a jury back in march acquitted thomas of
child endangerment resulting in death
but was hung on first-degree murder
prosecutors moved for a second trial
and thomas chose to be tried by a judge
rather than a jury
the judge convicted thomas of a lesser
count of involuntary manslaughter
that carries a possible sentence of up
to five years in prison
the judge's decision was based in part
on this so-called confession
from one of thomas's police interviews
jumped out of her bed and i tried to
grab her i tried her long and she
slipped out of my arm
i grabbed the pants and went like this
[Music]
um
[Music]
the judge seemed to agree with the
version of events that the prosecution
laid out during closing arguments but
held that the defendant simply wanted
chloe to take a nap so she herself could
rest
in other words no intent to kill and no
premeditation
the defendant told chloe you're gonna
take a nap
or i'm gonna beat you because she wanted
to make sure
she could rest chloe
like any other normal five-year-old
didn't want to take a nap
so she ran away from that bed
and what did her mother do she took
those pajama pants
she threw them over her pulled back
and strangled her with those pajama
pants
in chloe's last moments on this earth
she would fight for her life staring at
her
own mother we know that the defendant
intended to do this act
she intended to cause injury to chloe
chandler
there is no other intent when you take
pajama pants and use them in the way
that she did
so the facts the judge agreed with here
terry but not necessarily the intent
thing the judge said this killing
happened
in a fit of anger and frustration but
not with
malice a forethought or in other words
without premeditation
that makes a huge legal difference it
does and i can see where the judge may
have gotten to manslaughter but i think
what the judge is forgetting is that
the defendant here had multiple
explanations and to me
that means consciousness of guilt and
the other issue
at least based on the research that i
saw under iowa code 707
they could have had first-degree murder
charges here
based on the fact that it was a parent
or guardian who killed a child while
committing an assault and death occurs
so there's that and you know that wasn't
asserted here that wasn't
in any way shape or form part of the
evidence and i think we could have
relied on that to get this first degree
murder charge
so you're suggesting the prosecution
should have gone after this a little bit
differently
brian the judge also believed that
kelsey thomas was
just trying to scare chloe into taking a
nap
in other words no intent to kill
contrary to what the prosecution argued
so what kind of parent ties something
around a five-year-old's neck to scare a
five-year-old into taking
a nap so again this is the belief of the
judge
who is both the uh arbiter of the law
but also the finder of fact and now that
kelsey thomas is guilty i guess legally
speaking to say that she did this
uh but to answer your question aaron the
type of parent who does that is one
who's going to find himself behind bars
for quite some time
it's not one that i think we allow to uh
walk among society with the rest of us
yeah i mean the top penalty here is
potentially up to five years
it's it's a drastically lesser penalty
under this discount for which kelsey
thomas was convicted versus what was
charged
terry back to you the judge dismissed
kelsey thomas's claim that chloe hung
herself
on a dowel rod in her closet that was
about two feet taller than chloe was
the defense hung on to that claim till
the end almost but
the judge called it absolutely
unbelievable
well it was absolutely unbelievable
because it was just
one of the explanations that thomas
asserted here and
physically it's not even possible to do
that and so when you have a defendant
who provides
all of these different types of
explanations i do think it is
very difficult to believe anything the
defendant said and again
i go back to the fact i think she could
have should have been charged and
convicted
with first degree murder so brian back
to the legal tactic here
did the defense choose the correct
tactic by asking the judge
not a jury to try this case a second
time me specifically i am not a fan
of bench trials i go jury all the time i
think this was a mistake especially when
you look at
the previous trial and the reason why
this is a mistake because with a jury
you can say hey
this is what they're arguing they
haven't proved it but as we've seen here
with the judge
the judge can find a way to say i
validate this testimony but not this
testimony maybe some of this testimony
and then figure out a way to
involuntary manslaughter and i don't
want that as a defense attorney
it's a conviction but on a much much
lesser count so maybe the defense is
popping corks here to celebrate we don't
know
but it's possible and coming up after
the break here on law and crime daily we
take a closer look at 9-1-1 calls in the
police shooting death of walter wallace
jr
and police are looking for the killer of
a popular defense attorney in
ohio an emotional interview with a woman
who comforted the victim in his final
moments
when we return
[Music]
police in cincinnati are looking for
leads after a high-profile defense
attorney was hit and killed while
cycling
steve adams died last weekend and
engineered levy spoke with a woman who
comforted him
in his final moments after the crash
steve adams was loved in the legal
community and known for his colorful
personality
along with this tag line which was
stopped by the man
called the man now this is the area
where people have laid flowers
on the spot where adams was hit and
killed while riding his bike early
sunday morning
he was an avid cyclist a husband and a
father
annaleer heard what she described as the
sound of glass-hitting glass
she ran outside and found adams on the
ground and a teenager calling 9-1-1
i just sat out there with them until the
ambulance came i he
the kid talked to the ambulance i sat
there and talked to
his name's steven but i talked to
stephen and just could kept down and
hold on
you know the ambulance was coming he
wasn't talking but he was moving
his eyes and um his head
but he was uh and he was he was bleeding
he had his helmet on he had full gear
biking gear and stuff like that so
but he wasn't um i mean he wasn't able
to move until he heard the ambulance and
he tried to
roll over and get up there were a couple
of surveillance cameras mounted on a
building near where this crash happened
but police have not said whether or not
they captured any images of the crash
right now there are not any leads i'm
angenette levy for long crime daily
the minnesota judge overseeing the trial
of four former police officers accused
of murdering george floyd has set the
record straight after making a mistake
in a prior ruling
the judge recently agreed to try all
four defendants together in a televised
trial
the judge filed new paperwork admitting
he overlooked a so-called
rule 9 disclosure which outlined the
defense tactics
of defendant jay alexander king the
judge clarified that king
does not seek to blame derek chauvin and
that king's strategy does not
suggest he will be antagonistic to
chauvin
at trial when we come back the police
shooting of walter wallace jr
family and neighbors called police to
break up a chaotic scene
it all ended with wallace's death but
the 9-1-1 calls are helping a community
understand precisely what happened
you'll hear those calls next on law and
crime daily
[Music]
and now to the police shooting of walter
wallace jr in philadelphia we've spent
several
times these last several days reviewing
witness video and body camera video from
the officers who pulled the trigger
as wallace was moving about with a knife
officers said he was chasing them after
they responded to a series of 4-9-1-1
calls about an assault
the first call appears to have been a
hang-up the next call came in just
four seconds later from a neighbor
okay what's going on ma'am i don't know
the people next to a fight and the boy
back came back again in canada because
my house is fighting
and doing all kinds of stuff okay are
you okay yes i live next door
okay okay so we'll get police update
that is apartment b
right yes yes he said yes somebody
answered the quota cops right away okay
i got you
that was the second 9-1-1 call for help
the third call came in
18 seconds later from wallace's sister
i'm the daughter to my mother my father
and my brothers they called the cops
earlier
and the cops is not doing nothing he's
over there hitting my mother and my
father i'm always shouting how old is
your brother
he um oh my god he's 27.
any weapons involved no but he got a um
um a taste of he on probation and
everything he got a case for
um being violent and everything he got a
whole record
okay does either your mother or father
need a medic out there
guys my dad saying that he's about to
faint okay and my mom blood pressure is
all the way up
all right police will be enroute to help
them out but still online for medics
okay
screaming so i don't know what's going
on over there i just asked them
six one two four locus apartment b yes
police are going to help your parents
out let's stay on the line for medics
okay
okay thank you 40 seconds after that
third call came this fourth and
apparently final call
here the chaos becomes apparent the
audio is unclear but we've silenced a
few
small sections which may contain
profanity
61-24
oh
police and paramedics were dispatched as
those calls were in progress
officers were advised to use caution
because of what dispatchers called the
ongoing domestic situation
brian we've talked a lot about the
witness video and the body camera video
what do the 911 recordings most help us
understand
i think they're going to help us
understand the defense's argument here
if this case does get indicted and go to
trial i would expect that sister
especially
to be the defendant's first witness on
the stand she paints the picture of
elder abuse an individual with a
probation and a criminal pension
uh for violence and when the officers
are arriving that is their mindset
that's what they're going into and i
think this would be very damaging for
the prosecution
and great for the defense to kind of
excuse why they showed up in the way
they did
and again remembering this time things
are a little bit flipped it's the
defense for the police officers assuming
that this case
may go to trial so terry i'm hearing
phrases here just writing down as i
watch and listen to these again
it's someone with a record there's an
assault in progress
ongoing domestic situation and then
officers show up and there's a knife
immediately produced when the subject
walks out of the house
so is it reasonable for officers to go
into a situation like that fearing the
worst
well you know i think it is reasonable
for officers to have a good
understanding of what the situation
they're facing because they have to be
prepared to respond accordingly the
problem here is
the individual had a knife he did not
have a machine gun and i think that
they used deadly force when they could
have just tried to stop
him from what he was doing one other
thing i'll say aaron here
and i just heard it this time when i
listened to the recording the 9-1-1
operator said does he have a weapon and
the sister thought that or the daughter
thought that
he would she was saying does he have a
record and that's how they went into the
whole issue of the record so i don't
think the police knew
that there was a weapon on the scene in
any
event i think that it was just a knife
so i think it was just overkill
yeah in the final moments when he came
out that's when they noticed that well
not the
the knife i should say we're out of time
here on long crime daily we'll see you
next time discuss justice in america
[Music]
you